one thing that was incredible about that
character in particular björn ironside
was was that I got to literally grow up
on that show
and you can see that transformation on
film I don't think very many actors get
to be able to say that and and for me
that was a huge honor to be able to show
such an arc alexandra has spent five
years of his life filming the epic
Vikings TV series in Ireland but with
the upcoming season six being its last
it's time for Alex to start his next
chapter certainly miss it on Vikings but
on but it's great to be moving forward
and what better way to move forward then
joining the 100 million dollar
blockbuster Midway the Japanese are
planning something bigger so what's the
target
we believe it's Midway
Washington disagrees the film is
directed by Roland Emmerich the man
behind Independence Day Stargate and the
day after tomorrow so you know it's
literally going to be an explosive
blockbuster you were going to see some
huge explosions right now we're
currently filming I think the second
biggest battle of the movie I'm just
blown away by the true epicness of this
film I think they're definitely going to
do it justice and rolling in particulars
the director who knows exactly what he
wants and it's so refreshing you get to
work with directors like that we're
talking about a couple dozen plane it's
all Japanese asleep
this isn't a fair fight
you